you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens greetings greetings
citizens of the internet welcome to
tomorrow daily hello hello ready is the
best geek talk show their own universe
we are here sharing the gamespot live
co-op stage here at e3 2016 i have some
i'm ashley sceva by the way hello I'm
Ashley skele and I have some very
amazing people on the couch to introduce
you to you probably know them My dear
co-host jeff cannata hey guys how's it
going welcome to show a very special
show live from e3 and we're joined by
tim schafer that's you I hi thanks for
having me it's beautiful lovely here
then we are slowly becoming one plaid be
is all of e3 is becoming a plaid see by
the end of the show you'll be merged
into one flap there's one big beard
perfect amazing um you've got you guys
have a lot of stuff going on double find
us a lot of things when I go ahead
Lander but the thing I am most excited
about obviously as psychonauts the
rawness of really like to call pit roar
I don't know if you guys have I'm deaf
attack anachronism and that case is that
good anachronism I think so i think it
works um so let's talk about it i mean
Psychonauts 2 really big crowd fund guys
I know backer I have two full thank you
for backing oh thank you very much i
preciate that um and and so now you have
this sort of bridge between psychonauts
one and Psychonauts 2 and this is going
to be the experience we're gonna get to
have on PlayStation VR yeah even though
it's been you know 10 years and sweet
ship second thoughts won the events was
the rhombus of ruin takes place like
directly after that game ends and then
when rubbish room and Psychonauts 2 will
take off from there so this if you
remember the end of 2nd nuts I'm really
the end of 2nd odds that when they said
please now put on your VR headset yeah
and 10 years in 10 years when Arthur
invented put on your headset and so they
um you know Raz became a psychonaut but
then immediately the Grand head of the
second house Truman sonata was kidnapped
Taryn it happened to be his razzes
girlfriend's father too and so they all
jumped in this jet to go off to save him
and
that was the end of the game and then in
rhombus arun you see in that footage you
start in the jet and you're strapped in
your chair but you have your psychic
powers still and so r as can pick up
objects with his mind levitate them you
can burn them they can throw them he can
also use as one of those powerful skills
clairvoyance to see what someone else
sees so you can like I could jump into
your head basically then see the world
from your point of view you don't want
to do that scarf I kind of do and then
jump you see someone else you could jump
into their head and move around the
environment that way from brain to brain
to brain I really enjoyed jumping into
the squirrels brain that was really fun
yeah did you feel as little did you did
you like the nut joke I did yeah I don't
like quite a good nut joke that joke
waiting for everybody yeah we both hate
it and I I want to know just gonna your
what drew you to VR in this in the first
place I mean it's a pretty exciting new
technology are you sold on it well I
think like one of Double Fine's main
things we like to make worlds that just
pull you in and make you feel like you
just want to spend all day in this world
and you that you're really transported
to another place and VR just does a lot
of that instantly like the second you
put on the headset and you're there with
the characters and raz it and me is
talking to you and it's like wow I just
feel it's it's hard to explain until you
put on the goggles that if you can watch
footage of it but until you're in the
space you're like I'm in the jet from
the end of psychonauts and there's me
and everybody so it just really just it
really just drops you in a world that we
create really easily yeah I think one of
my favorite things about seeing me Mia
in front of you is you've always seen
those characters in two dimensions but
in a 3d space but now she's she's there
and it they're all so bizarrely shaped
but it feels so right like it was nice
to see those old friends again like
that's how I felt after I was done with
rhombus arun i was just like man like
I'm ready or after the demo yeah I'm
dying to play the rest yeah I've done
with it now I don't know if any more I'm
ready so you stay so you're in the plane
you're strapped in but then you
mentioned it opens up after you get you
get out of the plane and yeah other
different locations in there they're a
little
bigger the jet or showing this demo is
kind of a tutorial of how to use your
your psychic powers as a reminder a
reminder you know but is it gonna is it
gonna work the same way as the demo in
the sense that you're basically moving
around by at jumping from being to being
yeah we wanted to use an interface that
would be let you move around that made
sense in the world the psychic world of
the second up but also didn't run the
risk of making anyone feel like throwing
up because right if anyone's gonna throw
it's getting me I'm the first person to
get sick in the VR environments really
test your good test subject I'm a good
test subject and like this game is one
hundred percent you're not gonna barf
because you're you're only doing psychic
stuff it's almost like a point-and-click
in three-dimensional virtual reality
space it's a it's a look and click yeah
it is has it then it has almost
adventure game puzzles we're picking up
objects using them in the right places
and experiment a lot with the rise of
psychic powers side blasts coming out of
your head and blowing things up burning
things all the fun things as psychics
like to do all the things that we
enjoyed in the original psychonauts how
does it feel this year coming to the
show to be able to have that franchise
back one I know it took a little while
and also to be able to kind of say like
hey we're making that sequel and p i'm
sure people been stopping you and
they're excited about it aside for me of
course like I stopped you every time I
see him like hey thanks for second you
and then there's that guy look like you
in a mustache then did it yeah yeah
that's my brother ya know it is it's
ashley Esqueda yeah yeah mustache get
out get out game that has a lot of them
a lot of affection out there for the
game can i think the characters you know
the performances with the actors just
we're very charming and i think it's
like it really stuck with people and
it's been out for ten years it is it's
growing in popularity and digital
release and so there's a lot of people
who were waiting for it and then demoing
they at the the playstation event there
was like some half the people were like
oh I can't wait to see this a I played
the game ten years ago and some people
like I don't really know this is like
I've no idea and there's that's exciting
too because someone who's never seen
second us before being able to play it
and meet those carrots the first time is
also really cool yeah such a weird like
quirky universe to experience especially
a VR which I was a little scared that it
wouldn't be the same and then as soon as
i levitated the toilet paper so the
coach yeah I was just like oh man this
is this is psychonauts it's happening
and I'm playing it and I'm in it and it
feels so so right though you're in the
weirdness deep in the weirdness does the
the fact that you are inside it open up
puzzle possibilities for you or gameplay
opportunities I mean are you able to
hide something under something where you
have to let this it wasn't most fun
things for me it's like there's things
you actually have to move your head to
see ya and like a pin to this little
view thing and those feels so different
I don't think that would be a big deal
if you did it with a stick but when
you're doing with your own head it
really makes you feel like it's a real
it's a real object yeah sue me i
remember looking for pixels in you know
secret of monkey island enough yeah I'm
instead of like scrubbing your cursor
over other visual yeah actually like
right like bending over and looking
under things you get really terrible
neck pains now instead of a cursor neck
pain guaranteed take care to your knees
staring at everything uh so we're gonna
generally like wrap things I've one more
question about psycho nuts too can you
just tell everybody the entire plot of
the game right now raz is the robot Oh
what an alien who a robot I'll in well
it's still preliminary but they're
probably not gonna go with that plot
line but yeah thnkx events right after
you rescue German gelato and you go back
to the second lots headquarters and raz
is always dreamed of being a real psycho
not now he's really in second a hit
headquarters not at a summer camp
anymore and he gets to go on real
international espionage missions so
explain the real deal and now you've got
Zach McClendon doing dr. Fenton the lead
designer on bioshock 2 Bioshock 2 like
amazing good guys make great games is
I'm really excited to see this I thank
you so much for stopping by the same
revenue being an e3 just having a place
to sit down and a nice couch yeah that's
really how we saw this day here France
we got that's how we get people to say
yes really thats exactly chairs we had
chair guys I got a couch it's great
water um thank you so much for stopping
by ramsaran launch window for around at
the end of the yeah it's gonna be this
year in in the end was a year ish I
didn't know officially or I'll call the
lunch window the first three months so
yeah let's say let's say close to the
end of the earth good yeah okay yeah
alright ever you please give your round
of applause tonight
yeah thank you so much these your CR
Doyle citizens it's a really good I'm
really milking it now my as good as you
can check out double fine online we are
going to be coming right back with some
developers from destiny indeed talk
about their next expansion so stick
around for that don't click away to our
daily